I had to do something that was going to
convince someone 100 I wasn't no bill
but I needed to try and make sure that
it was legal
but I needed to do something and what
did you end up coming up with
we went to another Pub and they started
playing it was just there's this um
computer goal there was a game called
Dave Lee Travis's pop black thing right
by this thing right the question was who
won the World Cup in 1966
so I'm looking at it looking at it
they're all screaming at me that's right
you know Jim answer me answer me answer
it and then I just grabbed the sergeant
by the throat who had no idea what I was
doing he said why have you told him why
have you told him why why you know what
you know you've told them and he's like
well I don't know what you're going on
about and he didn't know but a clue what
I was going about
and I just went you know it's not my
fault I can't read or write and one of
them just turned around and went
well
my God you just as you accusing me of
being an old bill and he can't even read
or write because I then end up for 18
months having to make out I can't read
or write